d live is writing in asking how to
unlock I want to unlock my inner ability
how do i unlock making your ability I
think you know I tell you this guy is
great because that would believe I see
so many amazing entrepreneurs who just
sometimes lack conviction and yeah just
I've got a great guy lorenza we might
give a shout-out get a loan to come and
hit right come out come over back to say
can wait but learn these are from San
Paulo we have to be here he's dad email
me said you know you did this amazing
thing called safe summit Lorenzo can he
come do a day's work shadow yeah of
course why would I say no but there's a
rousing kids out there probably in come
from disadvantaged backgrounds who
either haven't got the not confidence or
conviction or just to say Steven can you
do this but this you know found
something like Evan always keyword is
ask ask ask and it's all about belief
it's all about conviction and if you do
that you'll explode your inner passion
and it able to externalize it and really
get people on your kind of movement and
your crusade to follow you your
customers and partners your colleagues
and everybody out there on social media
as well to really be part of your
volunteer army to build your success
thanks there you go um I think if you
don't know what your inner ability is
yet you need to explore you have a try
stuff I think people get locked in too
quickly on a career path that is not the
one that's meant for them and it may be
because your parents once you do that
you feel stressed out that you know
you're 20 years old and don't know where
you're going to go just as an example
what's your favorite sport I'm gonna be
blue jays now I'm converted baseball no
I probably hockey I'm field hockey field
hockey other people swap it cuz i play
them like you last year I played field
hockey I love stock Rockefeller a
jumping under seven I love Eddie school
anything with a ball in it I love it
okay so you know I love it let's let's
let's
soccer cos is kind of hormone us who do
you think is a greatest soccer player of
all time um that's a great question i
would say probably Pelle Pelle a okay so
and we go pelay whether he's number one
where these number three whatever I'd
like this always in the list i would say
that pili is not the number one soccer
player in the world of all time the
greatest player of all time is a manager
at starbucks because he never picked up
a soccer ball yeah because he never
explored does he never tried does it got
stuck on a path yeah and then never went
out to explore his options and so like
that guy could be pele o greater but
he's not he's doing some menial job or
low-level job or middle management job
right the point is you you guys could
all be the Pele of something and you got
to figure out what that is and you do it
by exploring and not settling like if
you wake up when you're look in the
mirror and that guy got to go do another
day of this like that's not the right
thing to do you got to go and find
something else and takes a lot of guts
and courage to not know what you're
going to do next but know that what
you're doing right now isn't enough and
so if you don't know what your nobility
is that's great you got to have the
courage now to go and try different
things and see what makes you come alive
and the thing that you love doing even
doesn't make any logical sense like
maybe you're too tall to be a jockey or
you're too short to be a basketball
player or whatever like don't let that
stop you from potentially finding your
greatness because you could be la at
something instead of doing what you're
doing right now yeah I think um we got
some amazing sort of explorers hair
talking about the parallels in terms of
entrepreneurship and exploring an
adventurous so got a great guy Justin
plancher who's climbed Everest sailed
around the world he's taking loads of
disabled service people off to the North
Pole on expedition South Pole and the
reason why I'm telling that is because
none of these guys thought it was
possible to do what they've done and I
think entrepreneurs would encourage you
to be adventurous explorers and reached
your highs climb new mountains and
unless you climb them you will never
know and then the the biggest tragedy
about life is you can kind of sit there
one year 50 60 70 80 and said I wish I'd
done that
you can grab the opportunity or letting
bit of carpe diem seize that opportunity
seize that moment give it a go no one's
going to die if you fail and I've felt
loads of times and stuff I've done and
I've always learned more and become a
better on from there and I just think we
would say entrepreneurs the spirit of
adventure and the spirit of exploration
has to be in their heart and that fuels
your passion